hi I'm Angie Rose training manager at
max Renner chocolate bar in New York
City here are ours must try desserts
first off we have our classic European
fondue it comes with three fondues of
your choice we recommend dark chocolate
our house-made toffee and white
chocolate fondue we've got one bowl made
with marshmallows cookies and brownies
the second bowl is pressed fruit
strawberries and bananas so when we
bring it to your table we light a fire
in the grill right in the middle so you
can grab those marshmallows roast them
off to perfection with these three
towers of fondue we have an array of
items for you to dip into it it's
perfect for sharing with all your
friends and family got a little bit of
everything in there to satisfy everyone
Italian thick hot chocolate which is
milk chocolate chunks with steamed milk
whisked down to a nice smooth texture we
then combine that with our house-made
vanilla sauce and while we steam it
the vanilla sauce starts to thicken
creating a velvety texture pouring into
our special maid hug mug it tastes like
a melted chocolate bar in a cup and as
you bring it towards your face with both
your hands giving it a hug it hugs you
back by bringing all the senses of
chocolate into your nose
next up is our s'mores sundae
we start off with some fluffy
marshmallow then some crunchy graham
cracker then we throw in two scoops of
vanilla ice cream two scoops of
chocolate ice cream some warm
peanutbutter sauce drizzled across the
top more of our marshmallow fluff on top
and it's hosted just like your around a
campfire served with white chocolate
fondue and a mounting heap of whipped
cream and another bowl on the side it's
like eating a sundae but it reminds you
of warmth around a campfire when you dig
your spoon from the top to the bottom
you get the crunch from the graham
cracker the smoothness from the peanut
butter followed by some more gooeyness
at the bottom with more marshmallow next
up is the waffle celebration with your
choice of three waffles we make our
waffles in-house we like to recommend
our classic banana split waffle our
brûléed bananas strawberry and cream
waffle mountain of whipped cream last
but certainly not least munchies waffle
but to make it a true celebration we
decided to throw on some sparklers
you'll add a little bit of powdered
sugar and some food Fetty sprinkles this
dish turns heads from the kitchen all
the way to the table this is a really
fun surprise frame
[Music]
last but not least chocolate chunks
pizza we start with our pizza dough milk
chocolate chunks then white chocolate
chunks put it in the oven to melt the
chocolate down so that we can load it up
with tons of mini marshmallows throw it
back in the oven bake it to a golden
brown once it comes out of the oven this
is our classic pizza but we recommend
getting it all fancied up with the works
with warm peanut butter sauce and
caramelized crunchy hazelnut chips so
when we deliver this to our table eyes
light up s'mores on top of pizza can't
come to Max Brenner without having one
of these it's been a favorite of our
guests of all ages for over a decade
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]